افادت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بانه تم احباط
محاوله من قبل كييف لشن هجوم كبير بطائرات
بدون طيار على اهداف في شبه جزيره القرم
وبحسب الوزاره اسقطت انظمه الدفاع الجوي
سته طائرات بدون طيار كما تم تعطيل اربع
اخرى عن طريق التشويش الالكتروني
ميدانيا قال مستشار رئيس الاوكراني
الكسندر رودنياسكي من قوات بلاده قد تنسحب
من بخمه شرق البلاد
الى موسكو لمزيد من المتابعه تنضم الي
الان مراسله العربيه كاتيا اهلا وسهلا بك
كيف تعاطت موسكو مع هذا الهجوم بالطائرات
المسيره على شبه جزيره القرم وهل نتوقع
ردا روسيا الليله على هذه العمليه
حقيقه هذه عمليه الهجوم التي تستمر منذ
يوم امس والتي تحدثت عنها السلطات يوم امس
على خمس مدن روسيه بالاضافه الى
الهجوم الذي
استهدف شبه جزيره القرم اليوم والتي قامت
الدفاع الروسيه بصده هناك نحو ست مسيرات
تم اسقاطها بالاضافه الى تعطيل اربع
بثيارات كما تحدثت الدفاع الروسيه وليس في
الاراضي الروسيه بل بالاضافه للاقاليب
الجديده التي تمت او ضمتها روسيا مؤخرا تم
اسقاط نحو خمسه عشر مسيره في كل من
دونيسكو
وخرسون ايضا طبعا السلطات الروسيه تتعامل
اولا تحدثت بالنسبه الى الكرمله كان قد
علق على هذا الهجوم الذي شنتته كما تقول
موسكو اوكرانيا كان
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني قد نفى طبعا ان
اوكرانيا هي من قامت بشن هذا الهدوء
الهجوم وبدورها ان كان قد تحدث انه لا
يصدق ان اوكرانيا لم تقم بهذا الهجوم وان
هذا جاء من الجانب الاوكراني طبعا
بعد هجوم يوم امس او بعد مسيرات التي
يستهدفت ضواحي موسكو يوم امس كان طبعا قد
تحدث خبراء عسكريون ان العاصمه الروسيه
موسكو هي محاطه بانظمه دفاع جويه قادره عن
اسقاط اي جسم قد يتوجه الى العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو وهي محصنه بشكل جيد عن اي
مسيرات او اي جسم قد يستهدف العاصمه طالب
اخر المعلومات الميدانيه عن الوضع في
باخمت اذا كان لديك
يعني المعلومات الاخيره هي تتحدث عن تقدم
القوات الروسيه والقوات فاغنر على الارض
هناك طبعا هناك طبعا الوضع صعب كما يصفه
بعض الخبراء العسكريون اشتباكات واسعه
وكما يتحدث الخبراء العسكريون ايضا هناك
شبه محاصره
للمدينه من الشمال ومن الجنوب لقطع
الامدادات العسكريه عن القوات الاوكرانيه
ولكن حتى الان لم يتم السيطره على هذه
المدينه ولكن كما وصفه رئيس القوات الخاصه
بان الوضع هناك صعب جدا وقد يحتاج الى
اسابيع للسيطره على المدينه في مدينه باقب
طبعا من موسكو مراسله العربيه شكرا جزيلا
لك كاتي على كل هذه المتابعه